there's nothing new in technology
transforming the economy from the steam
engine to the smartphone but few
Innovations promise change as fast or
fundamental as artificial intelligence
the stuff of Science Fiction that's fast
becoming a fact of working life
when you pick up the phone to a company
this is what you hope you'll get a human
to help sure I can set that up for you
over the phone send an email to octopus
energy and the answer might now start
with AI it's answering 44 of customer
emails just seven weeks after it was
introduced it's read every email we've
ever sent to a customer it's uh read
every training manual we've ever used
with our team it's read every bit of
Regulation I mean it's read every bit of
the Arcane back end of energy
kind of just knows it all right the boss
says it won't cost jobs here is a threat
to workers in The Wider economy around
the world governments are quite quickly
beginning to think about what they have
to do here uh but we haven't got time to
wait and see because uh you know look if
a freight train is coming at you you
don't wait till you feel it hit before
moving out the way that'll be too late
the first thing we need to think about
is this economic dislocation you know
risk to jobs
generative AI is changing the workplace
fast this London Law Firm has a bespoke
AI tool being used by three and a half
thousand lawyers in 43 countries just
three months after it was launched we
underestimated capabilities all the time
and then someone will send an email
going I just got the most amazing answer
I just found this use case it still
happens a lot on an individual basis
it's a boring productivity gain really
it's an hour or two week but when you
multiply that by three and a half
thousand that is a big deal for a
business well before this existed would
that been a realistic Target if you'd
been asked to find
three and a half thousand dollars it's
impossible it was impossible to find
these productivity gains through a
single deployment of a system a year ago
we couldn't have done this you can see
when the prompt is right the percentage
of you rolling a dice and generating
what you want is higher and that is the
prom crafting process AI is transforming
design two architects used to sketch
their Inspirations onto napkins and
envelopes now ai can produce thousands
of design possibilities drawing on
millions of real-life pictures prompted
by text or images I have to admit
there's always a certain percentage of
fear that always exists just because
it's I feel so revolutionary right now
and I can see it replacing certain
elements of certain jobs meaning that
the people who are not currently looking
into AI will realize it's taking over
and will be a bit caught off guard by it
it's just a matter of being able to find
the right methodologies to understand
the algorithm how it thinks and be able
to direct it so that you don't allow the
AI to control you or the output but you
actually curate the results
artificial intelligence could trigger
Industrial Revolution for White Collar
work with the prospect of huge
productivity gains coming with warnings
that millions of jobs might cease to
exist but the technology is moving so
fast we can't know where that balance
between promise and pain will settle AI
is already setting the terms of the
debate while politicians employers and
workers try and keep up the government
wants the UK to be a global leader in Ai
and will rely on existing Regulators
rather than new legislation opposition
unions says puts workers rights at risk
we say that at the very moment at which
regulation is most needed when the
Technologies are developing so rapidly
and the implications are so significant
instead of regulating the government is
putting forward flimsy and vague
proposals that don't have any statutory
footing you know
for developers there are huge
opportunities to create the means by
which we get AI to work for us but that
will come at a cost to some workers of
course there is a segment that is going
to be disrupted and that might lead to
genuine you know slows in job growth and
um just a reducing demand for a
particular type of work for that
category we need to take stuff like
Universal basic income seriously as
people start to lose jobs through this
automation of intellectual work we're
going to need to support them and help
them through that transition
AI will create new jobs even as it
consumes existing roles but it's moving
so fast no one can say where that line
will be drawn poor Kelso Sky News